[Music]
[Music]
you're watching reason live streaming to
you from Los Angeles the following is a
live conversation between the host the
guests and the online audience if you'd
like to participate please leave your
question in the YouTube chat the views
expressed by guests and the audience
members in this discussion do not
necessarily reflect those of reason and
now your host Zach why some more all
right thank you for tuning in for day 5
of 5 of the first week of this
livestream experiment I'm Zach Weiss
Muller we're gonna be talking with
reasons Oh Nick Gillespie and skeptic
magazine publisher and Scientific
American columnist and author Michael
Shermer and we're gonna be discussing
post-modernism rationalism skepticism
maybe a little bit of the intellectual
dark web which Michael is part of or an
associate of according to the New York
Times columnist Barry Weiss at least and
they'll be leading this conversation
mostly I might pop in once a while to
bring in your questions and also to some
clips from a previous video that we made
on this topic which is really what this
is kind of based on we got a lot of
interesting reactions to that video
which is called libertarian
post-modernism if you want to watch that
video if you're watching this stream
later and want to watch that first the
link is in the description so you can
take a look at that and honestly I'm
surprised at the amount of people who
have watched it all the way through it
is a 40-minute video talking about
post-modernism so it's a it's an
interesting time to be alive that this
topic has re-emerged for good and ill
critics and fans it's it's something
that people are talking about for some
reason and and maybe the discussion will
touch on on why this is something that's
even being discussed at this this
particular moment in time before we get
to that conversation I just want to
address a couple things one is last
night's stream with Christian O'Brien
was taken down
for a couple hours due to a what is in
my mind a bogus copyright claim
but it's back up now for you all to
enjoy and this the future of this stream
or this this experiment we're running
with live stream conversations we are
gonna revisit that in the new year so
this will be the last one of 2018 when
we're making the decision as to whether
to continue with this we're gonna be
looking at a variety of signals first of
all and most importantly engagement how
many people are actually watching it and
watching it you know all the way through
or or most of the way through and if so
first of all if you've been watching
these either live or later you thank you
for doing that that's giving us the
signal that it is worth the time and
energy to put this together and tie our
energy that it could be put towards
something else producing the other
products that we make it recent so the
other thing that we'll look at is just
the enthusiasm so you know are people
leaving good comments on the video are
people excited about what we're doing
you can leave comments or you can email
us questions at recent comm is the email
we've been using for this or you can
find Mia or Nick on Twitter and let us
know if you like today's conversation or
the previous ones and also honestly just
looking for feedback if if there are
this hasn't been perfect by any means
we're learning as we're going and so if
you have suggestions for how this could
be better or guests or topics you would
like to see that's really what I see is
the big value of this kind of thing is
getting that instant feedback in making
this a participatory experience
interactive so in that vein go ahead and
start posting your questions for Nick
and Michael in the chat and we'll be
working those into the conversation as
we go
and I want to start off this
conversation with a clip from that video
that we made libertarian post-modernism
a reply to the intellectual dark web
so we'll take a look at that and then
come right back with Nick and Michael
it's all they believe in is identity
there's no individual man that's gone
with post-modernism post-modernism is
actually pre modernism resurrected post
modernists are not really interested in
truth the level of irrationality that
grows out of this undermines the
opportunities for doing something really
significant and important this leftist
postmodern Marx and stuff that this is
the new religion show me a post
modernist at 30,000 feet and in a jet
and I'll show you a hypocrite if you're
a post modernist just to have a
discussion with someone like you
cisgendered male of power you know and
white to boot it's like that's that's an
evil act in and of itself okay Nick and
Michael welcome to the stream good to be
here thanks so that that intro is just
to show that this is a topic that's
being widely discussed on the internet
by a lot of different people and notably
by members of what's become known as the
intellectual dark web and one thing that
I had so Nick you and I made that video
together and we had a long conversation
about post-modernism and I did come away
you know with a few questions in my mind
you know after having time to think and
ruminate on it so I want to kick it off
with one of my questions and then bring
in Michael to start asking his questions
because I think he has a different
perspective from you as someone who's
been a critic of post-modernism but also
seemed kind of open to some of the
arguments I would actually I would
define myself as I if I'm gonna use
terms like modernist or post modernist
I'm more of a post modernist for sure
okay so here is your I want to start
with just your your definition the
definition you put out there
post-modernism and then ask you a quick
question about it John Francois Lyotard
he defined post-modernism is incredulity
toward meta-narratives which means that
you don't take knowledge or assertions
of knowledge as a given but rather you
understand that knowledge and wisdom and
even scientific understanding of things
it's not something that you you're
walking around and you discover in the
backyard you stumble across it like you
stumble across the Grand Canyon or a
mountain or something rather it's
something that's produced by humans and
as a result it's contingent it's limited
incredulity toward meta-narratives means
that you are skeptical of these big
stories that we tell about well this is
the why the world is the way it is this
is why it's always been that way this is
why it always will be that way or
alternatively this is why the world
should be this way which just happens to
comport with what I want I see that
phrase incredulity toward meta-narrative
as very simpatico with libertarianism so
incredulous the question that I'd like
to just have you what I'd like to have
you define here is just that term
meta-narratives
what exactly do you mean by that I I
think it's any large theory that seeks
to explain either all or part of the
universe and by that I mean human
society and things like that so you know
there there can be a single
meta-narrative which you know on a
certain level would be something like
evolution or the theory of relativity
there can be in political context or say
you know there are macroeconomic
meta-narratives that people believe and
speak to explain all economic phenomenon
using one or you know multi factors and
things like then so with meta-narrative
I'm using it in a shorthand leotard and
other people who really kind of
conceived of post-modernism sometimes
had specific categories that they would
call I use it in a more shorthand of its
it's any large kind of comprehensive
theory that seeks to explain a
particular phenomenon okay that's that's
a great start anyway I'm sorry to you
know interrupt you go ahead myself and
but you know libertarianism has a series
of meta narratives that are worth
thinking about you know that the world
works in a particular way that
individuals work in a particular way
reliably and predictably and the
important thing I think about the phrase
and this is where I think the type of
post-modernism that I'm drawn to is
distinct from some of what is criticised
as well as some of what is advocated by
post modernists or opponents of
post-modernism is its incredulity it
doesn't mean that we don't need
meta-narratives or that some
meta-narratives are not better than
others it's just that we always need to
be questioning we always need to be kind
of checking our assumptions and and you
know simultaneously I mean we're
building a house and we're also
constantly going down and making sure
that the foundation is not starting to
erode at the same time great and so
that's a great working definition of the
kind of post-modernism you're talking
about and I'd like to pass the torch to
Michael here to take it this this
journey in any direction he wants right
well I watched your your show yesterday
on a long drive down to LA and I really
liked it I thought Nick's pushing back a
little bit against Jordan and and Joe
Rogan's myself and others is good I mean
that that is kind of the principle of
post-modernism in a sense as you're
using it that is skepticism which is you
know what I do for a living
to a certain extent you know we move
toward truth or discovering truths about
the real world truths with a small T by
these kinds of back and forth and you
know conjecture and refutation is as
popper put it and but at some point we
we do get closer to something that we're
reasonably confident is probably true so
the meta-narrative of the Big Bang
origins of the universe the
meta-narrative
of the theory of evolution by means of
natural selection these are largely true
and superior to other meta narratives
that have come before based on empirical
evidence based on testing hypotheses and
if enough people convert people working
in the field scientists converged to a
conclusion we can be reasonably
confident that it's probably true again
with the small T and so while it's good
to be skeptical of meta-narratives at
some point it's also okay if they have a
lot of evidence to say well okay I think
you know we're converging on something
here very likely to be true and so what
those of us in the so-called
intellectual dark web are concerned
about is not getting to that last step
just being in incredulous for the sake
of being skeptical as I prefer to say
well you know I I think that you're
right about well two things one is I
essentially agree with you and people
who refuse to say that something is
factual or something is empirically
verifiable or kind of logically or
conceptually verifiable you know that's
a problem because I think that's where
you go into a realm of kind of non
rational thought and everything becomes
a kind of will to power to kind of mix
see we're just
errors of things and and it oftentimes
becomes very situational but so I agree
with you on that but my question then is
Michael where did you like where did you
start to emphasize truth with a small T
rather than the Apple T because to me
this is essentially the difference and
you invoked Karl Popper between
modernism and post-modernism and I think
post-modernism is very much a kind of
well I was I was gonna say it's an
Epiphone amin on of modernism but in
fact I think it's the true kind of
enlightenment ideal of seeking truth
moving towards enlightenment but also D
capitalizing everything so I attended
when did you notice yourself or when did
the scientific world stop talking with a
capital T yeah well for me when I
entered a doctoral program in the
history of science I was first in a in a
graduate program and experimental psyche
in the 70s and then due to a series of
contingencies I ended up being a bike
racer for about a decade and doing
something completely different then I
went back and got got my doctorate in
history of science
in between there I have taken courses in
anthropology back in the 70s in graduate
school and then I took another one and
so I'll just I'll just read to you what
I wrote here in my book at the
borderlands of science I wrote an essay
about my my collision with with
post-modernism and deconstruction I took
a graduate seminar co-taught by a
anthropologist and a historian in both
fields were being deconstructed by
so-called postmodern literary critics
and social theorists anticipating the
kind of anthropology done in the 70s
when I last studied the science the
customs rituals and beliefs of
indigenous pre-industrial peoples around
the world people like Napoleon Chagnon
and his work at the Yanomami I loved
that stuff I was shocked consumed
dismayed to find myself bogged down in
such books as Michel tossings the devil
and commodity fetishism in South America
with such chapters as fetishism and
dialectical deconstruction and the devil
and the Cosmo genesis of capitalism i
couldn't figure out what was going on
until the anthropologist announced his
was a marxist interpretation of history
that sees the past in terms of class
conflict and economic exploitation and
then i have a long passage here from the
book that's just impenetrable to me I
can't imagine and so this was my first
collision with this and then when we
started skeptic in the early 90s and I
started looking into the Holocaust
deniers and creationists you know they
were kind of being postmodern
deconstructionist of the meta-narrative
of the Holocaust and of the theory of
evolution and I realized if you take
this too far then you can actually take
it right into a classroom and go look
our story about the creation of the
universe 6,000 years ago is just as good
as the scientific one because there are
no objective truths and then you can get
really crazy and go okay and then I end
up writing a book about these guys
denying history about the Holocaust
deniers they just well our story that
you know this was exaggerated and so on
is just as good as the other historian
because there is no objective truth so
that's what bothers bothered me back
when I first collided with it and then
the clips you showed of Jordan for
example is emblematic of
the kind of postmodern wars that our
rear up together the 90s is captured I
think in John Heights got a nice lecture
about universities making the transition
from the search for truth to the search
for social justice and and he's got a
great basically challenge to them you
should just announce on your web page
which one you want are you helping
students understand the truth are you
helping students learn how to be social
justice warriors and just just be
upfront about it because that's what a
lot of them are doing and that's the
only certain we have yeah yeah well you
know and it's a concern that I share
because I you know when you look at the
19th century side you know that they the
gray kind of the arguably the three big
thinkers who come out of the 19th
century or Darwin Marx and Freud I think
Darwin's meta-narrative is the only one
that holds up right at this point and
it's been heavily change or it's heavily
modified and adapted and reinterpreted
so that you know in this this gets to I
think the benefit of post-modernism and
a kind of understanding of skepticism
and that D capitalizing you know taking
a capital T and turning it into a small
t is that throughout the 19th century
and throughout a good chunk of the 20th
century there were people who used
evolution or evolutionary theory and
kind of you know a what I think we would
agree as a bastardization or a
misunderstanding of Darwin and some of
some of the implications of which Darwin
himself didn't even understand that you
know particular races were better than
others and had a right you know
extrapolating from biology to politics
to rule over other people etc so to me
that you know you didn't I understand
your hesitation with post-modernism but
what does it mean to go from a capital T
to a small T and to me this is why I
find post-modernism particularly
simpatico I don't think it's the same as
libertarianism but it fits very well and
you know my background in terms of you
know my PhD studies were in literary
studies where literary critics
deconstructed the literary canon and it
was a couple a couple of things if no
one is
so what would essentially what they did
is they brought context back into the
creation of literary meaning and and you
know this is one of the things where I
think post modernists are wrong and this
is something that I first read in Hayek
but that they're applying kind of
methodologies or an understanding of a
field of knowledge in literary studies
or in history and then applying it say
to you know physics or Sciences that are
a distinct type of knowledge and
actually require a different way of
understanding the world and possibly
even truth I think truth in math or
physics is probably different than truth
in philosophy and like living philosophy
as opposed to logic or in literature I
don't think there is such a thing as
like the greatest writer of all time
what I'm interested in is the ways in
which we use literature and literary
tradition and create literary tradition
in order to have conversations and to
find meaning in our lives to express
ourselves to engage with people and
that's exactly what post modernists were
doing in literature in literary studies
starting you know arguably it goes back
further but the high-tide of this stuff
really started hitting the grad programs
in the 70s and 80s and early 90s when I
was in school and it was incredibly
useful because it was a corrective to a
really stale and boring understanding of
literature with capital L and here for
instance I'm an American s but you know
we were taught there were five great
writers that created something called
the American Renaissance which at the
time it was happening nobody it you know
the American Renaissance which took
place before the Civil War in literary
terms is something that was created in
like the 1920s and 30s or 40s by people
after the fact recover and then it was
presented as if oh well you know what
like we were just digging around in the
backyard and like oh my look at this we
found the American Renaissance and going
back and looking at what people at the
time were reading why they were reading
it how they were reading it and
recovering that and creating what Michel
Foucault who's you know one of the
bugbears of anti post modernists would
call a genealogy of knowledge rather
than just a received you know kind of
set of
Commandments there I find that very
helpful and I again I find a very
simpatico with libertarianism in
particularly when we start to talk about
kind of meta narratives of political
power or political righteousness yeah I
read fuko's book on I forget the title
but it was something like the the
invention of mental illness you know
mental illness was regarded in madness
and civilization yeah Madison
civilization you know madness madness
was invented in 1620 or something like
that you know it's like wait what I mean
we have some idea of brain chemistry and
genetics and schizophrenia is clearly a
you know a brain disorder it's a
malfunction of the neural networks and
so on what are you talking about okay so
I steal man his his argument I tried to
understand it and he makes some good
points that you know say something like
a more contemporary example the kind of
over prescription of ADHD medications to
young children who may not really
actually have some kind of brain
disorder but they're just active you
know young boys that like to run around
a lot and you force him into these rows
of desks and classrooms for hours on end
and the teacher can't control them so
they just they just medicate him up okay
that would be an example of something
that's you know called a disease as if
it's a medical the condition when in
fact it's just a social thing that we
embedded it in IDs to gain control over
hyperactive kids that would be an
example that I would say Foucault is
fair about but then then I was
introduced to Thomas oz in the 90s we
started skeptic people said oh my god if
you're a libertarian Shurmur and if you
didn't and if you you know if you're
challenging these these meta-narratives
have a speaky you got a read Thomas Oz
because he he's a psychiatrist and he
practices this and he shows that you
know there's no such thing as
schizophrenia it's like okay this is an
example of a good idea you know the
contextual basis of scientific theories
gone too far where you just say it's all
invented well it's not all invented the
narratives are structured around
something that's really out there yeah
well and you know it's an interesting
in the original video that Zack and I
did we talk about saws and Foucault
partly because in the early 60s along
with Artie Lange and there were a couple
of other people who tended to be psycho
psychologists psychiatrists
anthropologists looked at the
construction of mental illness as a
means of getting rid of people who you
know we're just annoying to the power in
sometimes you know sometimes it's your
family sometimes it's political
prisoners I mean there's a reason why in
the Soviet Union political prisoners
were routinely remanded to a psychiatric
institution I and saws and Foucault
fuko's first teacher gig in America was
that SUNY Buffalo in the late 60s early
70s and saws was up in Syracuse and they
actually correspond it fair matter I do
saws bit and it's I you know I agree
people say who have a better
understanding of say of you know brain
chemistry and whatnot that saws went too
far with what he was saying often times
or that he stopped keeping up with
advances in understanding you know
actual markers of disease but he wrote a
book called the myth of mental illness
I think that's powerful and again you
know a you know you everybody can take
everything too far there's no question
of that and to the extent the I think
one of the most ridiculous examples and
I'm trying to remember exactly where it
was from it might have been a journal
called October which was a left-wing
publication I don't know if it's still
around but where during kind of the AIDS
crisis or the AIDS era it hypothesized
that you know the difference between a
vagina and an anus was completely
socially constructed and that it was you
know merely the way we talked about
these things is what created the reality
that then somehow ended up with aids
infecting gay men you know that's wrong
because there is there are physical
differences and even if you're
heterosexual you're more likely to you
know get or at the time I mean we've
kind of moved past into a post AIDS here
abut you know the anus is not the same
as a giant in terms of intercourse and
there's more likely to have you know
bleeding which then leads to HIV
transmission etc
so you know Alan Coors the you know with
the guy who wrote the book the
encyclopedia of the Enlightenment for
Oxford or Cambridge press retired from
University of Pennsylvania I'm sure you
know we know him in common but he once
said you know there's a difference
between talking about the social
construction of reality which is what a
lot of extreme post modernists focus on
and they say everything is socially
constructed realities completely
socially constructed versus the
construction of social reality mmm I
think is where a post modernist
understanding and incredulity toward
meta-narratives becomes really important
and this is probably less so in the
research sciences in terms of you know
physics or certain aspects of biology
and chemistry and whatnot and it's more
in the way that science gets applied and
then trickles into politics or trickles
into different ways to control people's
lives jump in real quick with one
question I think is relevant these
conversation that came in from the
comments and also mentioned that since
you brought up Thomas's early next year
I am producing a documentary for reason
on this very topic kind of the history
of Thomas's and what he got right and
wrong and how what insights apply in
modern day and and which ones we
probably need to push aside so keep an
eye on recent TV for that next early
next year but this question is from
someone named simply irresistible and
and Michael Shermer brought up the idea
of steel Manning and this is basically
asking you to steel man the other side
to Nick what is the biggest problem you
see with post-modernism - Michael what
is the biggest strength so Michael was
about to talk so let's start with you
Michael
oh we're just parenthetically on saws I
we published an article by a man skeptic
because I'm always open to people that
that have counter views and lo and
behold I thought if I I found a some
supporters in Scientology that liked
what we were
about challenges in psychiatry I'm like
wait a minute what we're skeptical of
Scientology why are they liking my
magazine oh that's right they don't like
psychiatry hi the enemy of my enemy is
my friend kind of thing I guess for them
well for me I think I already said it
that it's clear that the old idea that
it's what a 19th century idea that
historians the job of the historian is
to just tell the past as it really was
well there's no such thing as it really
was there obviously you can't
disentangle the historian from history
and you know the the narrative writer
you know from the narrative the text
from the context that he's writing in
and she's writing in it and so on so I
think that's probably the best part of
it you know when I exited my doctoral
program in the history of science I I no
longer held that my original view when I
entered was that science is a sort of
progressing like an asymptotic curve
coming right up to but not quite making
the upper ceiling of truth with a
capital T we're get we're gonna get
closer and closer to it pretty soon
we'll get there so I gave that up after
the influence of post-modernism clearly
that it's not the case but on the other
hand there still is progress I mean
there's a reason why for example the Big
Bang Theory won out over the steady
state theory which we're competing in
the 50s and 60s and it wasn't clear
which one was gonna win out but the
evidence started piling up and piling up
and by the by the late sixties early
seventies it was pretty pretty clear to
every almost everybody with the handful
of exceptions like Fred Hoyle who named
the big bang theory just as ironic but
it is it's stuck and so why did that
happen why was there a convergence of
conclusions toward one theory than the
other and it's because the evidence is
there real empirical evidence not that
and not just that that I can see that
you can see and you and you and you and
anybody can go look at it and run the
experiment and so on so we can get out
of the postmodern trap that we'll never
know anything by
recognising that it's a social process
of getting out of my head to make sure
that I'm not deluding myself by having
you look at what I'm looking at and so
the whole idea of empiricism and again
poppers conjecture and refutation is I
put it out there into the community and
go this is my theory tell me if I've
gone off the rails if I'm looking at
something that might be real and then
you look and you look and at some point
we we converge to conclusion one way or
the other
and I think that's where we're at now
and Nick what would you say is the
biggest weakness of post-modernism i
think michael has touched on it it's you
know an intense i was almost gonna say
like an intense subjectivism it almost
becomes a form of intellectual autism
where nobody nobody can understand the
world as I experience or as the group
that I claim to speak for which I might
invent experiences and things like that
and there is a there is a move towards
the non-rational I wouldn't even say
irrational but it's that you know the
idea of if-then statements or the idea
of being able to submit the evidence of
how you came up with your system of
beliefs to where you you kind of open up
the data and you give people you know
the you know you show them what you did
and you say would you check my math for
me would you proofread my way of
thinking about the world and I think a
lot of the times the people who traffic
in kind of postmodern lingo or jargon
are that's something that they have
moved that they absolutely refuse to
engage in and you know in a campus
context that being shutting down speech
and I don't even mean you know I'm not
talking about somebody like Milo or Ann
Coulter coming to campus but really
shutting down the intellectual work of
engagement with people who disagree with
you so that you can actually move
towards a better approximation of
reality and there is an objective
reality out there but you know this is
obviously a very old concept but you
know there's an objective reality out
there that clearly impinges on us you
know with a you know with
something falls off the bill is safe
falls off a building and hits me whether
I see it coming or not it it hit me and
killed me but how do we how do we
apprehend that how do we comprehend that
and how do we make sense of it the other
thing that I would say is really is a
problem which I hadn't really thought
about it until this conversation but in
the counter-revolution of science
Hayek's book from the 50s called studies
in the abuse of Reason where he kind of
uses the French Revolution as the
paradigmatic enlightenment
driven mania where people you know the
French revolutionaries thought that they
could redesign everything at will and
just wipe out the past literally wipe
out the calendar wipe out every
distinction and just start over he talks
a lot about what he calls scientism
which at one point he defines as the
mechanical application of a system of
knowledge to other things which actually
run by different rules and I think in
many ways that's one of the problems
with post-modernism it really grew out
of history and literary analysis and and
in certain ways philosophy or the
philosophy of science or historiography
and things like that and I think it very
quickly was people started using it to
level all discourse and treat all
discourse exactly the same and that's a
problem because the whole point of
post-modernism is actually that the
world is is more complicated than we
think and that there isn't a single
Medan error meta-narrative or a single
system of knowledge that's going to
explain everything
let me read something I wrote here on
that where it shifts from the biological
to the physics and biology to social
sciences which gets more complex it is
my hypothesis that in the same way that
Galileo and Newton discovered the
physical laws and principles around the
natural world that really are out there
so to have social scientists discovered
moral laws and principles about other
about human nature and society that
really do exist just as it was
inevitable that the astronomer Johannes
Kepler would discover that planets have
elliptical orbits given that he was
making accurate astronomical
measurements and given that planets
really do travel elliptical orbits he
could hardly have discovered anything
else scientists study
political economic social and moral
subjects will discover certain things
that are true in these fields of inquiry
for example democracies are better than
autocracies market economies are
superior to command economies torture
and the death penalty do not curb crime
and that burning women as witches is a
fallacious idea that women are not too
weak and emotional to run companies or
countries and most poignant ly here that
blacks do not like being enslaved and
that the Jews do not want to be
exterminated
and now how do we know those things we
can just ask the people that are
potentially affected they're gonna be
tortured or enslaved they will tell you
I don't I don't want that so that's a
kind of truth I think that's what I push
you toward III you know I agree with
those truths but we also will recognize
that at various points you know you can
submit those arguments to the you know
to the world and they might not agree
with you or to say something like
autocracies are better than democracies
perhaps morally perhaps economically not
always or in a given period of time and
whatnot and I guess one of the questions
that I have and this was you know this
the I was interested in post-modernism
when I was in grad school and I was
expecting to become an academic this is
and then I ended up getting a job at
reason and you know I'll get back to you
know you know teaching at a university
someday I suppose but you know I was
going to use post-modernism as a way to
smuggle in Hayek and Mises in particular
as well as saws and a couple of other
libertarian thinkers because Michel
Foucault towards the end of his life he
actually in some of his last lectures
spoke highly of Mises and Hayek and said
that his students should read them and
and a kind of classical liberal you're
wearing a t-shirt I don't know if
viewers could say that says classical
liberal but that he was looking at
classical liberalism in the nineteenth
century as a way of hemming in certain
types of power and social control and I
was like okay well you know what like
let's Foucault in the late 20th century
was the most widely cited scholar and
most of the social sciences and
humanities let's look at these guys he
said we're worth looking at my question
for you Michael or a way of thinking
about this is what you know where do
those truths go once you start moving
you know like I think we would both
agree that men and women are
biologically different they're evolved
in different ways which are going to
have ramifications on broad-based
behavior patterns how do we use science
or how do we have a conversation that is
informed by science but then does not
become overly deterministic because this
is a little bit different than
post-modernism per se but it's this is
the problem I think that modernism had
which is that it very quickly devolved
into hyper determinism I think you see
that more now on the left and kind of a
Marxist left even more than a post
modernist left and we could argue about
Marxism and post-modernism when I was in
grad school these they were you know the
Crips and the Bloods they hated each
other right it's one the scientific and
the other was mush but you know how do
you how do you check yourself so that
you don't become deterministic yeah well
you did disentangle Marxism from
post-modernism in your first
conversation and when you do that
post-modernism doesn't seem quite so
dangerous but in the minds of many
people I think they're not disentangled
so for example you'll see in that clip
with with Jordan you showed you know
he's he's got them overlapped because
that's what I see he's in academia in
part because so many academics are so
far left-leaning they don't always call
themselves Marx oh and if I might just
inject I mean post-modernism and I'm
guilty of this too it's kind of a
garbage term right like we're debating
is it for everything either having the
joke that Umberto Eco the novelist if
philosopher who wrote
name of the Rose and Foucault pendulum
and you know is like one of the great
kind of theorists opposed modernist and
he said you know post-modernism is
something that you know any people label
it whatever they love I think we're at a
stage now to where it's people label
everything they hate as pretty so yeah
yeah so the concern like to bring up a
contemporary issue that you mentioned
was you know different men and women you
know I'm really afraid to touch that
myself although I touched on it a little
bit but Jordan got himself into so much
hot water for for talking about that
it's that's one of those taboo subjects
now but it's clear scientifically that
obviously there's physical differences
but but just on things that matter like
why there are gender differences in the
number of stem field graduates and then
jobs and it's clear that there's no
intelligence difference between men and
women you know the bell curve is you
know that the mean of the bell curve is
the same but when you look at the spread
of the edges there's a wider diversity
of men that the bell curve is spread
more widely than it is for women so as
Pinker says it's like in mathematics
more genius is it amongst men and more
dunces amongst men so yeah it's just
that it's just a wider range bell curve
so you get more extremes but if you then
shift to something like interest what
are men and women interested in doing
with their lives there you see a
dramatic gender differences that start
pretty early like in middle school when
and early high school and schools start
giving kids vocational interest tests
like what are you interested in doing in
most kids have no idea so they answer
the hundred and fifty questions on the
on the on the battery and see what comes
up the the male-female differences of
the kinds of jobs careers they would be
interested in going into ends up being
about the same percentage that they are
into you know decades later and so this
is one piece of evidence that it's not
intelligence as interest what are you
interested in doing look
what is the you know what is the reality
of things and say maybe not programming
per se which is a totally mysterious
dark art to me computer programming but
when you look at the culture of Silicon
Valley or the culture of Wall Street or
the culture of law offices or medicine
that were created you know and
particularly maybe something like Wall
Street or medicine like they were
created at a time when women were
absolutely not allowed to pursue certain
occupations and a culture of workplace
culture builds up which then is seen as
somehow you know god-given as opposed to
malleable or manipulable in a way that I
think we're seeing that you know when
this goes to your question of how truths
with a small T kind of evolve and any
quality and individuality triumphs over
time I think we're seeing you know this
this is where I think understanding the
construction of social reality yes yeah
which I said it's not unlimited but it
can change and it can change pretty
quickly I mean I think in our lifetimes
alone you know we probably have older
relatives who were smart women who
became nurses because it was unthinkable
that they would become doctors and
they're right we've become doctors yeah
now the barriers are down that they're
there last time I checked I think
they're just as many women MDS now as
men and there's certainly more in
medical school and the same thing in the
biological sciences and the social
sciences like in psychology it's like
7030 email you know maybe 6040 in PhD
programs but it's clear so the
evolutionary psych explanations but you
know boys are interested in things girls
are interested in people you know not
across the board of course these are
just average generalizations but what it
ends up resulting in is women are more
likely to go into the helping
professions medicine anything with
people and men are more likely end up
wanting to be involved with things and
programming I'm told because I'm like
you I have no idea so it's like it's a
dark art to me but programming computers
is more of a
being a guide thing then anyway this is
the explanation and it seems to me that
as you lower the barriers to entry
whatever results percentage differences
results that's reflecting probably more
interest than then say ability and and
also the other thing I'm gonna that
bothers me about these conversations is
this idea that somehow being a Wall
Street trader or a politician or
somebody that works you know a hundred
hours a week and a law firm to become a
partner or in the medical practice that
like that's the ultimate thing you want
to do to me working a hundred hours a
week this does not sound like a high
quality life you know to be the CEO of a
major corporation you know for thirty
years you've got to work the you know
the basically probably 80 hours a week
is something like it you know who wants
to do that that's not much of a life and
so women are more likely to say no I'd
rather work half time and spend time
with my kids there's a higher quality
life and somehow that's been transponder
fide into so you're saying that women
can't work as CEOs no and and you know
Pinker also makes this point you know
but you know why aren't there more women
Caltech physicists winning Nobel Prizes
or whatever because almost nobody could
be a Caltech physicist or mathematician
I mean it's such a tiny tiny percentage
of the population that could do it that
those extreme ends on the bell curve at
the genius and those slight differences
there are then reflected that's the
explanation I want to throw in a
question that was came up on the
original video because this is what a
lot of the critics of post-modernism
seem to be worried that it's undermining
a lot of the assumptions upon which our
very civilization is built I think this
comment kind of exemplifies it it says
here we go post-modernism implies that
all previous generations knew nothing
and that we know better it's perfect for
Maoist Cultural Revolution we should be
skeptical of established narratives but
an outright rejection of all narratives
makes us extremely open to whatever the
powerful today want us to believe and
they will change it at their whim as
expected
reasons rebuttal of jordan peterson are
dismissed with prejudice so this idea of
cultural Marxism that you hear people
like Jordan Peterson talking about is
that legitimate concern in any either of
your minds
you know I'll jump in I think you know
one of the things that post-modernism
actually valorizes is what a at American
literary critic from the 20s or 30s of
an what Brooks called a usable pass it
it valorizes rummaging through the past
to find examples of the of the kind of
world that you want or that that kind of
is a premonition of the world that you
want where that might be and to go back
and look at kind of counterfactuals
you know that you could spin out of
history so in a way I think I would
argue that post-modernism for me again
thinking about stuff like the revision
of the literary canon it didn't mean
getting rid of standards what it meant
was going back and opening up more books
and reading more books you read all of
the received wisdom and then you see
what else is out there that it's worth
talking about so I think properly
understood it's the exact opposite of
that it's actually inoculation against
the idea that the way the world that you
were born into is the way the world
always was and always should be I would
argue that but it is true I think you
know a lot of people constantly want to
just will away you know any any sense of
history and that's always a problem and
Michael what do you think of that
because Peterson obviously is very
concerned with the power of myth and
that you know our civilization is built
on a certain religious outlook and as a
skeptic I imagine you have some problems
with it but I'd like you to tackle that
and the cultural Marxism argument yeah
so your interlocutor over there he's
reflecting something like what edmund
burke's wrote about in his analysis of
the French Revolution that you can't
just throw everything from the past out
and start over because those people
figured out some things at work some
things that weren't such a great idea
like slavery
but other things in certain social
institutions that maintain a society
stability of the society and the French
Revolution went too far in throwing all
that out he supported the American
Revolution because there was a balance
there the French Revolution went too far
so a gala day but the or rather
libertine fraternity were pretty good
egalitarian gala ticket now back to
Jordan so I know Jordan pretty well I
like most of what he says but he kind of
flirts with some post-modernism when he
talks about the power myth and you
mentioned his podcast with Sam Harris
which I've listened to it was just you
know painful to listen to that you know
he could you know that Sam could not get
him to say you know this is really
absolutely true like this hands great
example was you know there is a correct
order of US presidents starting with
Washington and Adams and Jefferson and
so on and but let's say that a group of
you know Isis fighters have captured
somebody and they're torturing them and
they have to give the correct order of
the presidents of the United States or
else we're gonna detonate a nuclear bomb
in Los Angeles and and but the terrorist
has an incorrect memory of the sequence
of presidents so they kept the captured
person has to give the incorrect version
and and Sam could not get Jordan to say
there's actually a correct sequence of
US presidents and the terrorist has the
incorrect version of this and and this
went on and on back and forth and it's
like what is what is his what's the
holdup with technology and powers that
power and that power constructs
narratives it's really the
post-modernism stuff and well it's you
know let me ask you in terms of
evolutionary psychology or thinking
about that also Peterson it to me it's
not an accident that he's at University
of Toronto where Northrop Frye a
literary critic and cultural critic who
kind of liberated archetypal criticism
came out of her clients Brooks as well
other people like that
poly is very indebted to this but what
what do you think of archetypes I mean
are archetypes an emanation of a
biological of an evolutionary kind of
collective consciousness or is that also
mumbo-jumbo that I think it's mostly
mumbo-jumbo I think I think it's a kind
of class of a classification we impose
on nature of sorting animals into
certain categories and plants into
certain categories and things like that
that's perfectly that makes perfect
sense from an evolutionary perspective
from there you can start conceptualizing
ideas into categories which you know can
make some kind of sense that's kind of a
form of abstract reasoning where I think
Jordan gets a little messy is is when
you ask him like do you believe in God
and you know his answer it you asked me
that I go no yes
ask him that because that would take me
40 hours to answer it's like why well
what do you mean by belief and what do
you mean by God and like for example
Jesus was resurrected okay so people
like me and Dawkins say no he was not
resurrected that would be a miracle
violation natural you're conceding he
existed so you've what I didn't but for
Jordan he you know he wants to say
something like Jesus is a archetype of
absorbing the sins of the past and
redemption starting over you know he's
got this whole story and that's really
true it's okay what do you mean by true
I mean as an archetype as an idea yes I
get that you know the the idea of Jesus
dying for me and redemption starting
over the flood myths for example whether
it's true it's probably not true but it
represents some kind of truth like you
know people can start over and rebuild
their lives and so if you read a novel
that inspires you to do this or you read
a religious texts like the noachian
flood or the Jesus story it's kind of a
destruction Redemption we're starting
over
and that's true for you okay I get that
it sort of metaphorically or archetype
archetype only but not true
scientifically not empirically true do
you you know
I one of the things have you ever been
to the Creation Museum outside of
Cincinnati yeah yeah and I'm forgetting
the name of the guy Keith whatever I
can't hate them can have yeah I mean you
have to consider it in an enormous
concession that that whole museum which
is extremely well done and I find it
enjoyable and not simply on an ironic
level although it's just that you know
that they're arguing in scientific terms
like they're using the language and at
least the appearance of science and
logic in order to make their case it
seems to me that that's a gigantic
concession and I am curious if well
that's right before like the century ago
no one really cared about scientific
discoveries in terms of their
implications for religious beliefs um
but most didn't because most weren't
basing their religious beliefs on facts
and evidence and empirical reasoning and
arguments and logic and all that it was
just what they believed so this is a
very modern idea that science is now the
power narrative and if you want to power
in culture you have to use that
narrative to get your message out so at
this I at the Creation Museum you go in
there as you may recall there's two
pathways you can go down the science
pathway and you end up in this room
where there's you know sex drugs and
rock and roll and euthanasia and
abortion and you know it's just you know
that culture has gone to hell in a
handbasket all thanks to you know Darwin
and then you go down the other path when
you end up Jesus in heaven and love and
everything is great so they're really
kind of post modernist you know in a way
as you've defined it they're saying the
meta-narrative you tell ends up it's not
a it's not a just a hypothetical
interesting discussion about DNA or the
age of the earth it it has implications
for politics economics ideology beliefs
life and death morality where you end up
after you die and so on do you do you
also believe that though because I guess
one of my questions and the this
conversation has been helpful for me I
mean to kind of clarify this idea of
taking a you know what I mean kind of
arbitrage a system of knowledge
developed in one field and then putting
it into another sometimes I can yield a
really interesting and
other times it can lead to confusion and
I like categorical confusion which I
think when post modernist and I think in
the clip that Zack showed at the
beginning he was talking about or you
were talking about you know show me a
postmodernist at 30,000 feet and I'll
show you a hypocrite
I think I came back to something along
those lines of saying like yeah that you
know that you know it's true but like
what does aerodynamics the science of
aerodynamics and there are certain wings
there are certain engines or a certain
you know measurements that are more
efficient and more effective and keep us
from crashing and we can we can model
these and predict these and retro dick
things and everything but what does that
have to do with living a meaningful life
which is really ultimately the arena in
which we're gonna spend most of our
lives so you know but what does
astrophysics have to tell us about you
know whether or not our our you know our
children should you know become doctors
or lawyers yeah so here you know let's
get back to the charge of scientism
which I'm guilty of I think the mistake
here is thinking that when you're
talking about like bridging the is odd
gap and using science to find meaning
and morality but here we're not talking
about science like theology we don't
turn to the ichthyologist to find out
what the meaning of life is or or what's
good and evil or what's right and wrong
here I'm just talking about the whole
body of the Western tradition science
and philosophy the in throw in theology
and and literature and the arts
everything we know when you throw in
religion now I went through in religion
because the you know they were there
before science and they've been thinking
about these things a long time and they
didn't have a systematic method to get
at the truth so to speak the scientific
method but through trial and error they
figured out some things that were better
than other things and so and some
religions are better at this than others
I I think because Christianity went
through the Enlightenment it came out
more civilized it's become you know
reasonably supportive of most moral
civil rights movements and things like
that they're slow to change but Judaism
is probably my top
I was going to be religious it would be
maybe a Jew even more than a Buddhist
and most of the Jews I know they're
atheists but they still you know the
cultural tradition back to Burke's idea
that the certain things people have
discovered in the past we should hang on
to because they work by work what do we
mean you know less violence more
prosperity a more stable society these
sorts of things we know that certain
things work better than others just like
we know planets travel in ellipses and
so there's some value there I think I
tend to agree and I think you know one
of the things that I was I was raised
Catholic in a Catholic tradition like a
Jewish tradition and like Protestant
Reformation Protestant tradition is a
skepticism actually towards
meta-narrative I mean obviously you know
getting together and arguing about the
finest you know every jot and tittle I
mean some of my best friends are
biblical literalists and one of the
things that I as I became more
interested in literary criticism that I
found was a you know a kind of common
ground was like every Lynn turists in
understanding a text and you know they
would talk about how every jot and you
know that God breathed every jot and
tittle into the King James Bible which
strikes me as a ridiculous statement I
mean you know every comma and every
period every punctuation mark much less
the longer passages and that is a good
that that you know regardless of how
it's being done you know that process of
kind of being conscious and trying to
ferret out a better understanding of
what you what you're looking at I think
is a good one yeah so if you find value
in Jane Austen or Shakespeare or
whatever like that Dostoyevsky you know
jordan loves michi and Dostoevsky well
there was no brothers Kara's Karamazov
in Russia that I know of but it's
irrelevant that's not the right question
you know what is it true it is is that
an accurate true history of the
modernisation of Russia in the 19th
century it's that that's the wrong
question it's irrelevant you know a lot
of people that send us articles about I
have an explanation for the noachian
flood it was a you know meteorite or a
volcano you know whatever or Jesus
didn't really die you know when he was
up there on the cross somebody gave him
some stuff that knocked him out and his
heart break it was super low and they
thought he was dead but he wasn't that
he escaped and he went to France and you
know and so it's sort of a Dan Brown
novel kind of thing at this point but
but but to me they're they're going down
the wrong path I mean I like the
scientific approach to these sorts of
things let's find a natural explanation
for this apparently supernatural
phenomena but maybe there's nothing to
explain
maybe the stories are just mythic
they're archetypal stories that
represent something people just make up
the story to deliver some kind of moral
homily or message that is true in that
sense but not true in a historical
scientific sense and another question
came in that I think goes to what you
were talking about Michael and and maybe
challenges it a little bit
I mean you wrote a book called the moral
arc which I interviewed you about and
Sam Harris also seems to have and I
don't know if you this is a correct
characterization of your beliefs but
that there are kind of moral goods that
can be rationally derived and one of the
questions that just came in from d4 and
Nabal why should we care about
individualism or egalitarianism etc why
not attempt to make the state as
glorious as possible all those questions
can't be answered by science what say
you I he's wrong I mean we we know what
happens when the state gets glorified
and the collective is put over the
individual we have tons of historical
experiments the experiment has been run
and they're almost always catastrophic I
mean not almost all these boys now if
it's a tiny little commune of you know
20 people in nineteenth-century Kansas
or something you know it's relatively
harmless people have a lot of sex and
because their feelings hurt and the cult
leader ends up absconded with the money
whatever but if you scale that up to the
big communist experiments and the 20th
century then you end up with a hundred
million death and the problem is that
it's too easy to rationalize why we need
to suppress those individual rights over
there or even get rid of those
individuals in the name of this greater
good this collective you know kind of
archetype of the state as representing
us and all that that and it's too easy
to sacrifice people and that's what
leads to you know major body counts in
genocides and and Wars so yeah we know
that's wrong and would you agree that in
certain profound ways and I think I
interviewed Steven Pinker about
enlightenment now and I think one of the
relative weaknesses of the book which i
think is fantastic and it's one of the
you know the best things I've read in
memory in recent memory is that things
like the gulag things like in a way
Nazism were participating in a broad
enlightenment narrative and in the sense
of like when you were talking about how
you fetishized the state and everybody
has to everybody becomes kind of data in
or you know some kind of integer in the
formula for greatness and for you know
for collective greatness and whatnot and
it seems to me that recognizing and this
is something where post-modernism you
know I think this is one of the ways
that that capital-t truth was demoted to
a little tea was that people understood
pretty quickly in the 19th and early
20th century that's very easy to start
kind of losing your perspective and like
you have the truth and then you want to
impose the truth on the world and it
ends very poorly yeah that's right yeah
although in the case of the Nazis and
the Communists this was more of a post
enlightenment romanticism move in soil
and you know the kind of elevation of
the people the folk to something grander
than the individual yeah or and yeah
it's it's simultaneously both pre-modern
and kind of postmodern and then I guess
I you know what is a more accurate way
of putting it is that then they used the
kind of fruits of you know kind of
modern industrial technique and
yeah really kind of get where they were
going in a relatively efficient and like
Francesca Lea effective life yeah
here's the way I phrased it some of my
critics are accusing me of basing my
ideas on weird Western educated
industrialized rich and democratic
culture that that's my embedded
presumption about immoral progress so I
write sure future scientists may one day
discover that humans do not have an
instinct to survive and flourish that
most people do not want freedom autonomy
and prosperity that women want to be
lorded over by men that animals enjoy
being tortured killed and eaten that
some people like being enslaved and that
large populations of people don't object
to being liquidated in gas chambers but
I doubt it okay so I think where do you
take where does the family and kind of
shifts in family life because again and
and and I'm thinking about this in terms
of a kind of you know science that is
flavored by post-modernism so that you
we recognize that if evolution is true
we're evolved to have tighter kinship
ties to people who are closer to us
genetically or you know that we grow up
with but then also we recognize that
there's an a wide variety of family
units and even within our lifetimes and
certainly within the lifespan of the of
the United States exactly how family is
constituted how it is defined and what
it means can change how you know so we
know you and I are both good
libertarians we we don't like the state
we don't like the collective we don't
like you know probably you know the
group is important but it should be
voluntary and whatnot but then how like
how far down can you burrow into the
family being a kind of voluntarist unit
rather than something that is dictated
by evolution yeah they're I think the
evolutionary psych tendency is to see
the family as an extension of your
genetic autonomy it's it's different
than any other collectives although you
know hunter-gatherer groups are small
enough
everybody you know that everyone in the
group knows each other pretty intimately
and and if there's not genetic ties
there's at least a lot of reciprocity
that has gone on and so you get
reciprocal altruism along with kin
selection as kind of binding the group
together the the challenge comes from
extending the family and extended family
to much larger communities in society
once you break Dunbar's number of 150 or
so and you end up with a thousand or ten
thousand or a million then those then
you need some kind of external networks
of trust for people to be able to
function and so the long debate as we
know you know while we need a state well
maybe we don't need a state maybe you
know you can get these kind of bottom-up
self-organized principles like in the
west where miners and ranchers just
drafted their own contracts and
agreements sometimes that works
sometimes it doesn't work sometimes you
end up with bottom-up mafioso gangs just
fighting it out and levels of violence
go way up so that that's where I have to
say you know solving the problem of the
social problem of cooperation in large
groups is really hard I want to go ahead
and just we're coming to the end of the
stream but there was one persistent
reaction that we got to the original
video that I'd like especially Nick to
address and that is that we were more or
less straw Manning the other side and
not really talking about the same
post-modernism and in this conversation
you've already conceded that
post-modernism is a garbage term but
maybe we could just talk a little bit
more about that and then wrap up soon
here's one example of such a comment
stupid video this is a 40 minute long
straw man of Peterson's views on
post-modernism Nick basically redefines
post-modernism as it was originally
intended instead of addressing the
bastardized version of post modernism
which Peterson and others are obviously
criticism there saved you 40 minutes and
then I was talking yesterday
with Christian O'Brien of 1791 a YouTube
channel and he was wondering if we are
just conflating post-modernism with
skepticism and should we just be talking
about skepticism so any response to that
Nick you know you have to define your
terms and you know I was using the you
know the incredulity toward
meta-narratives which i think is a
really good working definition of
post-modernism and it's in the work that
really introduced post-modernism to you
know into intellectual discourse so I
stand by that there is no question that
we you know when I think when when
people start saying look you know
left-wing postmodern Marxist
you know blah blah blah like you know
something is going on there and it's not
what the railing against might
absolutely be true when I find you know
are in one of the clips you know that
you that you showed in our video Zack
where Jordan Peterson said that the
individual disappears and post-modernism
like I think that's just factually wrong
i I don't I don't see that at all as
deriving from the assumptions of
post-modernism or even the ways that
it's often applied in in in the way that
he means it having said that you know on
college campuses today there is a you
know people appropriate or or either get
charged with being postmodern or or say
that they are in terms of saying that
everything is well to power that there
are no logical arguments that all you do
is you shut down you know either you're
being shut down by the powers that be
because you have a conversation they
don't want to hear or you are the person
shutting that down I don't know how you
get around that and what do you think
Michael is there a straight line from
post-modernism to the campus identity
politics and what I think Peterson calls
you know power games is that a straight
line and is that a legitimate criticism
post-modernism may be clarified it's
called Marxist post-modernism or
something like that you know because
there's probably different types that
you know so Jordan is reflecting that
time when
talking about what's going on in the
Academy yes I mean for sure that's that
that's the whole idea of power or
structures and the oppressed and the
oppressor and you know the oppression
Olympics is it's sometimes call now and
you know that's the kind of thing that's
being discussed at least on some
campuses I don't think it's epidemic on
all campuses but it's it's widespread
enough that we should be concerned about
that and it's particularly when spills
over into the sciences like biology how
many sexes are there how many genders
are there you know these are slightly
different questions when you get into
the gender issue you know it's tied to
biology but to what extent you know does
culture play a role obviously some but
part of that I think you know just sort
of close out here what I have to say
about this is that it's this kind of
binary thinking we're in where we want
to put things in boxes and categories
okay that so there's two sexes there's
two genders that's it I mean you know
Ben Shapiro he grants it it's funny the
way he rants about this but we but
that's that categorical thinking that
there is a slight spectrum of like less
than 1% of the population has these
genetic or hormonal differences that
make it a little fuzzier okay we should
recognize that and say okay you know
0.05 7% of the population is not clearly
male or female fine
they don't fit in either box and that's
okay in science you can have these kind
of spectrums you don't have to put
things in just in boxes and I think that
kind of categorization of things in the
boxes gets us into trouble and you don't
have to just pick up on that I think you
know one of the great things about the
21st century and about intellectual life
in the 21st century is that I I would
like to think of my more optimistic
moments that we're replacing binary
thinking or you know either-or thinking
with spectrum as a concept in a lot of
different ways and you know as a
description of reality because and you
know I have exact I think we talked
about this in the original thing I'm
actually a big fan of intersectionality
which originally is a term that was used
in feminist critiques of power and
whatnot and it ends up often being the
worst kind
of identity politics where you stack up
all of your partial overlapping
identities and then you know whoever has
the most impression points or who is
from the most the least empower gets the
most power that's a problem having said
that as a way of understanding who we
are and what makes us up and what
communities we belong to what identities
we have it's I think it's a it's a
fantastic very postmodern way of
understanding if modernism is the idea
that one theory or one idea can explain
everything post-modernism is that
actually we need more than one because
we're more complicated as individuals
and to Michael's point it's you know
again for me I guess and this is partly
because I I'm not a scientist so I don't
have to worry about these things as much
but it is kind of when we start talking
in terms where we take supposedly
hardcore scientific truths that are
immutable which and they're always
contextual ultimately on some level at
least in the language we use to describe
them what happens when we put that into
a social or political order and
particularly you know Michael I would
love to have this conversation I'm like
where does your individualism come from
where does it spring forward forth from
because is it evolution or is it you
know is it nature is it nurture is it
you know your mother when you were when
she was pregnant had a particular type
of mumps or measles and you came out an
individualís is it epigenetics I'm not
sure where mine comes from but that's
the question you know that I'm I'm kind
of obsessed with and do me this is where
post-modernism obviously it can be used
I guess like everything it can be used
to shut people down or it can be used to
kind of rethink things and really
challenge the ability of the state or or
the corporation or the family you know
all these different sites of potential
repression and oppression as well as
empowerment to begin on us now you know
like that's the conversation that I feel
that we learn is and yields interesting
results for we will have that
conversation on my science elan podcast
in weeks but but you brought up
intersectionality theory you know this
is again another example of a good idea
just taken too far in the Academy that
that really does end up being the
oppression Olympics and by
away that term was calling by a Latina
feminist activist who warned her
followers don't turn this theory
intersectionality theory into oppression
Olympics which is exactly what's
happened so the print the problem is is
when you put it into action from just
the theory so if a black man says to me
a white man Shermer you have no idea
what it's like to be a black guy in
America he's right I don't I I know I
have privilege being a middle-aged white
guy driving a Tesla around Santa Barbara
I know I'm not going to be assaulted I
know the police aren't going to shoot me
you know I I just I'm relieved of all
those things that I know let's say a
black guy has to worry about but a black
woman could then say to the black guy
you don't know what it's like to be a
woman much less a black woman and yeah
and she's right you know and so on and
you can start the premise of a John
Lennon Yoko Ono song for the early
seventies woman is the N word of the N
word of the world because she's the
slave to the world slaves probably could
a white guy probably couldn't sing that
song now it lets you just said n-word
yes I want to wrap this up with just
Nick you mentioned earlier and in our
video also that this is in many ways a
way for you to kind of smuggle in
talking about people like Hayek and you
near the end of his life apparently
Foucault was a fan of Hayek and I want
to just play a short clip of Hayek that
was featured in that video and then
really have you explicitly draw that
connection for us to finish us out so
here is a little bite from Friedrich
Hayek socialism assumes that all the
available knowledge can be used by a
single central authority it overlooks
that the modern society which I now
prefer to call the extended urban which
exceeds the perception of any individual
and is based on the utilization of
widely dispersed knowledge and once you
are aware that we can achieve that great
utilization of available to resources
only because we utilize the knowledge of
millions of men it becomes clear the
assumption of socialism's as a central
authority
command all this Marge ok can you tell
me those eyeglasses are back he was a
hipster well that you know in a way that
was one of the things that I think
Foucault Michel Foucault was
particularly drawn to he ultimately
rejected classical liberalism or liberal
kind of enlightenment hedges on Perry
didn't think that they've worked in
offer that it was not quite up to the
task but I think you know what Hayek is
tapping into there is a rejection of
19th century you know the worst strains
of 19th century enlightenment thought
and I think in the in the person of Marx
and to a certain degree Freud as well
you saw that kind of hubris fully formed
later in in the 20th century where
central authorities did start to say we
can control everything we can control
the price we can control you know the
time or that you know the time zones and
things like that so I think you know if
if in fact Michael you know went from
starting grad school in a period where
truth with a capital T was a live option
and then when he came back to it it was
truth with a small T I think it's partly
because Hayek who is very much in a
following it was heavily influenced by
Karl Popper they were together I guess
for a while at Cambridge but they you
know by stoppers understanding of the
limits of knowledge and I think that
that's you know that's the best part of
post-modernism that it's right at the
minute when you're about to throw the
kill switch and you know jerk you know
you know either
like you know create the gulag or you
know let the you know the dam wash over
you know water wash over an entire
society or civilization that lived in a
valley forever because you know you're
gonna do the right thing for the
greatest number of people I think you
know that that thought in our mind that
says hold on we really ought to we ought
to run the math again we ought to check
our math I think that's tribute to Hayek
and I think that's post-modernism and
it's at its best great well that's a
great closing more remarks any final
thoughts from you Michael before we wrap
up that was a perfect way to wrap it up
I am deeply concerned about the Chinese
movement toward planting like a hundred
million cameras all around the society
to try to dissolve the Hayek problem of
knowledge we're gonna know what every
single person does every minute of the
day and then we're gonna reward them
points or diss credits for everything
that they do that you know there are
people still trying to do this and they
they have the kind of technology now
that the you know the germ the East
German Stasi could only dream of in
terms of knowing what everybody's doing
so we have to keep pushing back against
that well thank you both for this really
enlightening conversation I think this
showed the potential of this forum and I
hope that you those of you who watched
agreed I mentioned in an earlier stream
that I was thinking of this week as a
kind of sample platter so I tried to get
a little bit of lenore scapes kanae's
you talking about parenting some
psychedelics a philosophical
conversation between Nick and Michael to
cap it all off and I hope you enjoyed it
I I know I did like I said we'll be
taking a look at if it makes sense to
continue this and part of that is going
to be reading the signals the viewership
the engagement so let us know through
all those avenues commenting email
Twitter whatever if if you like it or if
there's anything that you would like to
see done differently or guests that you
would like to see come on the show but
for now we'll leave it there and see
we'll see you in the new year on Reason
TV and in any case with our regular
programming documentaries interviews
Stossel videos remi videos all your
favorites
so thanks again for tuning in everybody
and have a happy holiday and Happy New
Year
[Music]